one of Hollywood's fastest rising stars
was arrested over the weekend here in
New York and what police call a domestic
dispute Jonathan Majors is charged with
multiple counts of assault and
harassment of an unnamed woman a lawyer
put out a statement claiming there is
evidence proving Majors is Innocent but
there's already some Fallout from the
charges the U.S army has dropped an ad
campaign featuring Majors while the
investigation plays out but Lee Luciano
has won the story
the gloves
currently seen
and starring in the cree lead and
Ant-Man hit movie franchises have I
killed you before was arrested and
arraigned in New York this weekend
police say they responded to a violent
domestic dispute involving majors and a
30 year old woman shortly after 11 A.M
Saturday according to the criminal
complaint the NYPD said he struck the
woman's face with his open hand causing
a laceration behind her ear and grabbed
her hand and neck causing bruising the
33 year old actor was arraigned that
same day and released without bail under
a limited order of protection the next
day Majors lawyer said she expects all
charges to be dropped saying there is
video footage from the vehicle where
this episode took place witness
testimony and two written statements
from the woman recanting these
allegations which proves that Mr Majors
is entirely innocent and what is that
video need to show whether or not Majors
engage in any sort of physical behavior
that would rise the level of criminal
Behavior Majors is also featured in the
U.S Army's recently rebooted be all you
can be ad campaign and if you have the
will to make the world the best it can
be
the Army has a place for you but a day
after his arrest the Army's marketing
office issued a statement saying it is
deeply concerned and is pulling the ads
until the investigation into the
allegations is complete Major's next
court date is set for May 8th the next
hearing could be a pre-trial motion
essentially or it could be a statement
of we're dismissing the charges for CBS
mornings I'm Lilia Luciano in New York